las calles de moscú están inusualmente
tranquilas para una mañana de mediados
de semana este jueves comienza un
confinamiento parcial en la capital
durante los próximos diez días sólo los
comercios esenciales permanecerán
abiertos y los mayores de 60 años que no
están vacunados y han recibido la orden
de quedarse en casa hasta febrero en
todo el país este fin de semana comienza
una semana de vacaciones pagadas en un
intento por frenar el mayor repunte de
kobe 19 en rusia el kremlin ha advertido
que no se debe viajar aunque dice que
cerrar las fronteras regionales sería
una medida de último recurso pero
mientras las medidas se endurecen los
pasajeros hacen cola en el aeropuerto
moscovita de sheremetyevo sinceramente
no tengo miedo están tratando de
manejarlo incluso de los hoteles no son
mis primeras vacaciones este año
probablemente sean las escriben tendría
por supuesto todo esto es desagradable
toda esta situación es muy estresante
pero que se puede hacer es una pena
renunciar a tus planes los médicos que
enfrentan este nuevo flujo de pacientes
no comparten esa opinión si todos los
sitios no se gestione esto persiste las
situaciones no hay camas libres muchos
pacientes se encuentran en estado grave
y en las unidades de cuidados intensivos
el gobierno sostiene que el problema
radica en el lento ritmo de vacunación
con sólo un tercio de la población
inoculada en medio del escepticismo con
la vacuna pero muchos señalan a las
autoridades culpando las de enviar
señales contradictorias desde el inicio
de la pandemia el año pasado